Bogert McFarland good to see you sir
from Monday Night Football always man
thanks for having me man this is like an
honor for me stop don't don't say I mean
I'm thrilled that you're here rams
ravens tonight downtown and that's a big
game but I want to go down a little bit
of memory lane with you yeah 15th
overall pick of the 1999 draft out of
LSU congratulations on what should be
the Heisman Trophy winner by the way
just in case y'all don't know that Joe
Borough Heisman I think that right now
it's it would be quite something make
chase young would have to take shape and
Patterson down like 9 times an existence
with that game coming up this weekend
but so you're the 15th overall pick in
the 1999 draft does Dungey call you get
you on the phone Rich McKay calls for
it's McKay calls he was a GM at the time
and then I talked to coach Dungy I mean
I was I was at home in Winnsboro
Louisiana we had like a big party at the
house like it wasn't really popular yet
for the guys to go to New York and nor
did I really want to go because I grew
up in a small town about 3,500 people
three or four stoplights and sort of
people that were very important to me in
my life I wanted to celebrate with them
and so we had a huge party there was
more catfish fried and really barbecued
that day in my town and probably ever
before right we had a huge 80 inch TV
set in the backyard and the moment that
sticks out to me about that day is my
mother was born in 1955 and so she saw a
lot of things growing up and for her to
raise a young man that was able to get
drafted and I was actually in her room
when the phone rang and you know Rich
McKay comes on and he says we want to
make you a Buccaneer and he pass the
phone to coach Dungy it was like I was
happy and it was fulfilling for me but
to see the smile on her face and the
tears coming down her face man just I'll
never forget that moment that moment was
more special to me than the two
championships I want yeah what bucks and
and the Colts as well but the Bucs and
this is this is a fun question I look
forward to the answer you show up yeah
okay and there are you won't walk in the
locker room and there's Alstott there's
done yeah you know there's Derrick
Brooks yeah but there's one individual
in particular that's in your position
group
warrants up welcome you to the team
booger his first thing was because I
held out my rookie year the contract
wasn't done for two days no yeah so you
can imagine how that goes right so so so
I show up and the first thing he says to
me was you know now that you're rich can
we please get to work and I was like
yeah sure and that's what he said to you
absolutely that was were the first
things he said and so for me playing in
playing in the same position group as
him I got a chance to watch him work
every day and for all the the
extracurricular things that are said in
and around him he's still the hardest
work I've ever been around no kidding
how he shows up how he works
now sometimes getting him to work is a
little different but when he shows up
yes and I'm only talking to the
offseason but when he's at work yeah he
works as diligently and as hard as
anybody I've ever been around and being
in that defense was like what for you
it taught me taught me so many things
that I still use in my life today
because defensive football at its core
is 11 guys coming together and it's
really not that hard
like defensive defensive football is not
like putting together an orchestra you
know because in an orchestra you got
them you got to make sure man that every
guys on the right tune in the right time
defensive football is about 11
individuals doing their job and on the
smallest details like stopping around
for instance stopping the run is no
different than math in school if they
have several yards of block you need a
guys to kind of counter that so you can
make the tackle but plan for that
defense we were very simple we only had
about ten defenses rich I still remember
them all today but we were built on
doing the the little things the
fundamentals the techniques and effort
effort we coached effort and we taught
it in and we used to try loafs meaning
if you were not giving all-out effort
when I play you would be called out and
peer pressure was the number one thing
that fueled our defense because you
didn't want to let the other guy down
and Monte Kiffin Tony Dungy Rob
Marinelli they believed in a system that
was simple that allowed guys to play
fast and if guys will play fast and give
effort you have a chance to play really
good defense
oh now by the way they had Hall of Fame
players to that system now you can be
dumb
Lynch's a hall-of-famer right he should
get in no doubt yeah he's close he
should get in Ronde Barber should get in
how you revolutionized the Nickelback
position right
semia rice is gonna be close I think
people have a view of him as a guy to
just rush the passer that's not true
especially we got the temper cuz we
forced him to play to run so if you look
at the defense app saying Brooks in I
think Lynch should get in barber should
get in Simeon rice on the fringe I mean
so you could realistically have five
Hall of Famers offer our championship
well you got Dungey to although part of
what got him in as well was winning the
championship for with him in
Indianapolis what was it like for you to
win one with and for Tony because
clearly the one in Tampa was with Gruden
at the helm what did that mean it meant
a lot and I'll tell you the back story
so the night Tony got fired in Tampa
I'll never forget it I'm watching the
local Bay news 9 in Tampa and they're
filming him as he's walking out of the
Bucs facility got one box in his hand
he's walking toward a jeep during go and
it's raining and just that seen how that
scene looked out I was at home watching
it
fast-forward he goes to Indy they trade
for me I come in he tells me just be
yourself and that'll be it that's all we
need we make a Super Bowl run only Super
Bowl - that's every Super Bowl 41 it's
pouring down raining and so the irony of
how he got fired
and for him to win that Super Bowl in
the rain and for me to be with him now
also remember when we won a Super Bowl
with the Bucs
I didn't play in the game because I had
a broken foot and so having one - but
having played in the one with Dungy in
the rain the only Super Bowl dat at
seven reign we carried him off the field
it's just like I don't believe in
coincidences in life I believe in things
happen for a reason you know I think the
good Lord upstairs has a sense of humor
sometimes and for it for the rain when
he got fired to be there and for the
rain to be the Super Bowl and that this
it was it was a great story
I've learned more from Tony Dungy as a
man then as a football coach that's
saying something but you know for me to
be a part of that team with him was
really spell
bugger McFarlane here on the Rich Eisen
show Monday Night Football with you and
Joe testator and Lisa Salters and John
Perry oh I think it's terrific he's
phenomenal I know right yes in this day
and age everybody's got to have a rules
expert at that the at the ready yeah
because I think the rules have become
the center of attention and regardless
of whether the NFL likes it or not you
need somebody to kind of make it really
simple where it's not digestible at home
and the fans can understand it and
that's tonight
Rams hosting the Ravens what a big game
first time you're gonna lay eyes on on
Lamar Jackson this year Ravens haven't
been on Monday Night Football - yeah how
do you see this one playing out what is
the key to it Booker McFarland well you
know the Ravens are physical football
team oh boy are they and their identity
they're not arrogant but they believe in
what they do and they're gonna run the
football whether that's with Ingram
whether that's what the quarterback
they're gonna make you feel that's
you're in a football game now sometimes
you've gotten play teams it's like it's
basketball on grass it's it's screen no
no no no this team here they won't take
you in the phone book and take a bat and
just hit you upside the head over and
over and over and at some point right
you either gonna stand in there and
fight back you're gonna give up I think
that's the type of game we're gonna see
tonight like they're gonna try to line
up and say Hollywood la Walk of Fame
Microsoft theater Staples Center Holly
all like the stuff can you step into the
ring and get into a fist fight you know
can you do that well Erin Donald you
think they're equipped he said he's
equipped that that's one game right
aired on a complaining type of game got
it he's only one right Jalen Ramsey can
play any type of game that's - now can
you get 11 guys to do the same thing can
you get 11 guys to step into that ring
and be in that fist fight that'll be the
key because I think on the other side of
the ball when the Ravens defense is on
the field yes they're gonna do
everything they can to take Todd Gurley
away and this game tonight comes down to
does the Rams defense want to get in a
fist fight and can Jared golf throw
under pressure and under duress I would
think if you're asking those questions
of me my answer to the first one be held
Bram's are gonna get in the fistfight
Kurt Aaron Donald is ready okay we've
seen Aaron Donald you've seen I don't
know the throw people around like that's
he likes throwing people out of the club
like that's part of his then club99 he
likes picking people up and throwing
them out and a bunch of people can
follow Wade Phillips I think we're
talking that's if you want to get into
that game let's go that's gay I think
that's the game we're gonna see but the
the offense for the Rams I'm I'm
concerned about that can golf stand in
there and and be the one to wing it
around what do you think that's the
question that's the million-dollar
question if Gurley is in fact removed
for the game yes and we did see some
flashes of 2018 Gurley 25 carries
against a team last week in the Bears
and to know he was coming downhill at
them correct and I think the Ravens feel
like what they're - interior tackles
with Petco and Williams that they can't
do that against them mm-hmm you know and
so now can Jared golf and on the outside
because I think it's gonna be good on
good tonight
you got cooks you got Robert woods you
got Cooper Cup flip it over the other
side you got Marlin Humphrey you got
Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Smith right and you
got Marcus who's got a chip he's got
that bowl of gumbo it's good it's good
I'm good and so when you have good on
good on both sides right now comes out
in the quarterback and Jared golf I mean
he hasn't played well this season he
hasn't and and I think overall that's
gonna beat it if he if he plays well
tonight I think we're gonna be in for it
it's not gonna be like like Rams Chiefs
was know anything back there but the
score may be a little higher but if he
doesn't then LA could be in trouble
Booker McFarland here on the Rich Eisen
show I mean that game that you called
the hole I mean we were all talking
about it heard that the death of defense
defense is dead in the NFL because the
way the rules have been made to put the
the the offenses on skis and the defense
is on their heels and yet it seems to me
that the script has totally flipped the
other way since that night the Super
Bowl being the example of it mm-hmm that
we have seen the way the Patriots have
created this defense started that night
against Gulf
and we have now seen the entire season
playing out where the 49ers are gonna
come down and hit you and have that
defensive line we see what the Patriots
are able to do right now we're talking
about the Ravens do you think that the
script has flipped in the NFL you do
what I think it has happened if we go
back a year ago the the advent of the
rpoS and all that the college game came
to the NFL and it became wide open and
so now I think what you've seen is
you've had a year four defensive
coordinators who don't really like
hanging with their families or going to
the beach they spent the entire
offseason they've studied all this film
right and they've said okay so how do we
combat that defensive coordinators are
being more aggressive a lot more man
coverage a lot more lets dictate to them
and not allow them to dictate to us so
what's the rillette what's the response
do you think that that might be coming
here because Rod Woodson told me many
moons ago this how many moons ago was
Boca respond when the Wildcat was going
crazy yeah
it was yes okay I said right that's what
he said to me yeah but I said to him
like man while everyone's doing walk out
the Dolphins were killing it with
Wildcat and and he said like that give
defensive coordinators one offseason
give defensive D different corners one
offseason they'll fix anything know is
what he said so is this is this the
responses to the rpoS that we're seeing
everything I think the aggressive style
and the man coverage is a response to
your question what's next yes I think
you're gonna see it tonight Lamar
Jackson and you have to find I think
offensive coordinators are gonna say
let's find that quarterback we're
already seeing it Tyler Murray Marv
Jackson who's gonna be next the college
game is gonna give the NFL some more
guys like that could Jalen Hertz be a
guy like that he may not have the
twitchiness that Lamar but dual threat
quarterback where the quarterback can
become a runner I think he's gonna be
the wave of the like the next wave of
the future because now it makes you play
11 on 11 normally what happens when when
the offense is running a play whether
it's a pass or specifically a run
quarterback hands the ball off and he
becomes a spectator now what happens if
the quarterback is a part of the play
see defenses are used to play an 11 on
team because once the quarterback hands
it off he's a spectator
it's 11 on 10 mm-hmm now with Lamar
tonight it's 11 on 11 same with deshaun
Watson staying with Kyler mother dak
Prescott now that's when you've seen
these offenses are becoming more and
more unstoppable like look at the top
offenses in football
Dallas dual-threat quarterback he's a
password but he can run lamar the top
russian team in the league calimary
rookie season but he's been phenomenal
if you look at where the even Patrick my
Holmes who is the the quintessential
pocket passer still has movement
capabilities we saw that last Monday
night against the charger so the dual
threat quarterback is their response and
I think the answer to the man coverage
in the aggressive semi that was crazy in
Mexico City less than 200 yards passing
but led his team in rushing that was
Patrick mahomes I mean and then we did
we haven't even mentioned Russell Wilson
yeah I mean booger McFarland here a few
more minutes with him on the Rich Eisen
show that Monday night game we had Bobby
Wagner on the next day and I'm like
every play ended with a thump and every
one of them it felt like a playoff
atmosphere what in the hell is it like
calling that one that had to be
something yeah you know when you get
games where the game comes down to the
end like we have a saying in our
production group when the game is that
good let the game speak for sure yeah
back off right back off let it speak for
ourselves you know when the game is it's
17 20 points then you got to kind of
polish it up a little bit and make it
you know a message that's what you got
to do of course you know when you get
games like we had last week like we've
had the Seattle game like we hope to get
tonight you a lot of players to just
tell the story all you try to do is just
add just a little bit of flavor to it
just a little bit of analysis to the how
to the why what's coming next and liking
things of that nature so I look forward
to those games because I think live
sports is the greatest reality TV we
have in this country no doubt and
football being the number one sport in
the United States we got the greatest
reality TV show every Monday night and I
think when you get to teams that are
playing against each other on Monday
night and the entire country is watching
mm-hmm I think everybody's captivated
social media is captivated because
everybody's got an opinion
all these armchair analysts but for the
people at home we got to remember this
is entertainment and so there's nothing
like sitting at home on the edge of your
seat not knowing what's gonna happen
when you get high level athletes
competing and to me that's the fun part
about III my pitch myself every Tuesday
morning man that you know when you get a
chance to call Monday night but
especially when you get a game that goes
down to the wire because I know what
it's like to be in that arena you know
there's an old poem talked about the man
in the arena and if you've never been in
there you don't know what it's like and
we try to bring the fans in the arena
and for me to have been that arena it's
it's special man well I know during that
game you mentioned many times that you
thought Russell was the MVP then honors
by week Lamarr goes for four touches
who's the MVP through I think today as
we you know Thanksgiving week here I
think you got to say it's Lamar I mean
but all Russell does is win
I think it's developed and it's amazing
how it changes it's kind of fluid I know
it's very fluid I mean again Russell
what he did that night and by the way
there's no hard and fast rule but I
think the rule is if you're going to
play an overtime game with Russell
Wilson don't give him three
opportunities I think all teams
especially gives you the ball within a
sec correct which was so stunning I mean
it literally got me off my seat when
that happened that said the way he
played that night yeah for sure I'm like
unbelievable way that he ran for the
first down to set up the win after
making these incredible throws that
throw returner who I'd never heard of
before I'm being very honest before he
caught that pass in pirouette so all
that said Lamar is amazing I mean and
and then at some point you do have to
talk about Michael Thomas in a way maybe
I'm missing I'm missing this last money
not about Michael Toma because they're
not in - man well and they're not in -
and he's not only the primary that like
every time Sean Payton designs a play
Michael Thomas is one to end the third
receiver and they're like their dad look
at him pretty much every play but I
think if we really want to be honest
tonight will go a long way for a little
Amara to cementing the award because
last time we had Russell remember what
Russell did it wasn't a great
statistical game
right but he made the plays when he
needed to make them yep so tonight for
Lamar you want to submit the MVP award
you go out and you make the plays he's
gonna have the ball in his hand tonight
a lot and here's the thing I marvelled
about Lamar everyone wants to take
credit how we knew was gonna happen we
knew this was gonna come huh huh let's
go back to the playoff game against the
charges 50 minutes of football
he completed three passes and the entire
stadium in Baltimore were screaming for
Joe Flacco that's less than a calendar
year that's last January the entire
stadium in Baltimore were screaming for
Joe Flacco give the kid a lot of credit
because the offseason was huge for him
how much better he got the the
dedication of work that he put in and
the support that he got I mean you know
you got this is a great staff you have
around here and I'm sure and they do a
tremendous job of making sure you're in
position to succeed that's what the
Ravens have done bringing Greg Roman
Marty morning week and I'm really know
okay don't worry about it let's bring
Greg Roman in he has experienced Tyrod
Taylor Colin Kaepernick we know what to
do with the mobile quarterback and so I
think you have to look at what Lamar has
done from that game against the Chargers
to where he is now such great
improvement you got to give a lot of
credit to himself and the staff around
there and and how they've built the
entire organization around him and doing
that he's rewarded them and he's leading
the MVP race right now well then let me
finish our conversation with our poll
question which is the top two teams in
each conference the team to beat would
be which it's that you got the page you
guess who by the way lowered their
average touchdowns giving up statistic
from 0.9 to 0.8 one more game it's crazy
and then you've got the Ravens tonight
then you've got the Niners who just boat
raced Green Bay coming off that's bye
week with the Saints in a shootout at
home one of the most the most
entertaining game of yesterday which
team is the team to beat so if I look on
the NFC side here's what I'll say
I think Kyle Shanahan if he's not the
best play caller and run designer in
football somebody needs to show me
another person they have a style that
plays anywhere anytime against anyone
they have a defensive line
they got 5 first-round picks they get
after your quarterback and they make
your offense they made Aaron Rodgers
look like he shouldn't even be a Pro
Bowler last night because they pressure
pressure will force any quarterback to
look like that so I think on the NFC
side it's the 49ers I get it some people
aren't sold on Jimmy Garoppolo I'm not
even saying I'm sold on him but Jimmy
has performed and answered all the
questions so you can be kind of lukewarm
on Jimmy that's you I think the 49ers
are the team to beat on the NFC side on
the AFC side probably surprised people
I'm gonna go with the Patriots and I
know they haven't looked great
offensively what at 10 and 1 mm if they
stayed at that game whoever they plays
gotta come in Foxborough it's gonna be
cold it's gonna be wet maybe Lamar and
the heart and John Harbaugh
has a history of went in there he's been
there all right but let me ask you a
question this was a rhetorical question
yes in January will you trust Brady and
Belichick or Lamar and Harbaugh who do
you trust
I hear you and I think that's what you
got to come down to I think winning in
the regular season is one thing at home
in Baltimore I'm not saying it kid I'm
just giving you my opinion I think going
to Foxborough when it's gonna be five
degrees in late January the wind is
gonna be blowing we're not gonna be a
total football I know you're gonna run
it you know you're gonna run it can you
still run it can you run your
quarterback is he gonna want to get hit
when it's when it's windshield zero all
those things factor New England has done
that and and and I something tells me
that Belichick wants that matchup he
wants Ravens in Foxborough against Lamar
especially after way the way Lamar
embarrassed them in Baltimore this year
so I would lean Patriots AFC 49ers yeah
you know Bella check will be talking all
week long if that's the AFC Championship
matchup yeah they say we stink
they say you know oh you know he'll do
kill use that or without that but you're
using your your logic and it's it's very
sound logic wouldn't who would you trust
on a on a championship Sunday and the
NFC though Peyton in breeze or Garoppolo
and Shanahan I mean to a Peyton and
breeze but man now I'm getting my
feelings a little bit with this
defensive line though because I did
because the 49ers
good it's so good so young too young and
they're gonna have to make decisions in
the offseason with Armstead and Buckner
and I get it and d-force but he like
they haven't played to their full
capability yet because Ford has been
hurt right with the knee tendinitis and
so imagine what happens when they get
really going and Kittles been hurt and
Saunders has been in and out of like
they haven't really and and and think
about this no Jake McKinnon this year
Quan Alexander's hurt so the people that
or the team that they could be we still
haven't seen and we and we may not see
it this year but I just love what John
Lynch former teammate of mine has done
out there I think the world of Kyle
Shanahan I just think they built the
right way
much like the Patriots are built the
right way Patriots are running football
team now Brady tries to supplement the
offense when he can that's why he's so
frustrated because he's used to throwing
50 touchdown passes and all that and
he's had to mentally go from being the
greatest quarterback of all time which I
think he is too
we're not doing those things anymore and
I can't have a bigger as big of an
impact on the game and it frustrates
great people it's no different but then
when Michael got to a point where he
couldn't he couldn't get up and do 360
dunks we're Kobe didn't have the lifts
great players get frustrated and that's
the frustration you see from Tom Brady
I'm sure also too cuz he thinks me or or
he here is that people interpreted as
he's getting older or longer in the
tooth and there might just be the
circumstances in the roster I mean
Judaism he's targeting Jacoby Myers 15
times any in any any whole country's
watching week 12 game against the
Cowboys man I could keep you here for
the whole hour I could stay here for
this is fun this is great
enjoy to call in tonight's game looking
forward again Ravens at Rams tonight on
Monday Night Football and then Minnesota
at Seattle next week
you also have Green Bay at Minnesota to
wrap up the season and by the way San
Francisco's against a New Orleans not on
your air but that games coming we will
of that and I think it's gonna be a
low-scoring affair because the Saints
defense is pretty good also at ESPN
burger on Twitter and at SEC booger on
Instagram LSU Tigers number one overall
hot boudin baby during the Monday Night
Football booth life is good for you sir
it's good thank you sir bugger me
farling here on the Rich Eisen show your
phone calls when we come back on the
Rich Eisen show do you want to quickly
tell you about the happy Honda days
sales event going on visit your local
Honda dealer for great deals during the
happy Honda days the Honda cars and body
a fun to drive spirit and these the cars
that are right now at your local Honda
dealer under the spotlight the 2019
Accord the 2019 Civic sedan the 2019
Civic hatch sophisticated sporty and
aggressive all respectively loaded with
tech apple carplay Android auto
integration remote engine start the
Honda sensing keeping you safe on the
road letting you know when you stray out
of your lane or if you need any help
letting you know when to brake guess
what there's Honda sensing and their
standard for all Accord in Civic Sedan
hot hatch models if there's roomy
passenger space cargo space as well and
if you want to add a little extra kick
the turbocharged engine and paddle
shifters they're available to add more
thrill to the performance of these
vehicles so visit your local Honda
dealer right now for great deals during
the happy Honda days sales event eight
four four two Oh for riches the number
to dial we do have a couple phone lines
open will clear the banks when we come
back for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app